I'm uh wherever the camera is you know
if I'm shooting this young lady who's
sitting right here with the glasses and
we're putting the camera right here I'm
right here looking right at her and here
we go every single actor with if it's
your cousin who you talked into doing
the movie and he's the worst actor in
the world but he's got red hair and you
need the guy because he has red hair and
he'll do it for free or if you're
talking about Christoph Waltz it doesn't
matter if you're right there by the
camera when you say cut they will all
look to you to see what you thought
they're acting for you they are just
acting only for you so don't be in
another room don't be watching TV you
work too hard to be watching TV while
the most exciting moment of your life is
happening be there look at their eyes
see the environment around them the
frame for a little bit you've got the
frame you know what the frame is
supposed to be see what's outside the
frame you know but also you're just
feeling the drama of the scene